- [Voiceover] This program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(relaxing music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Frances Dinkelspiel.
She is an award winning
author and journalist.
And is the 2016 Harvest Lecturer
Distinguished Women Lecture Series.
Her most recent book is
Tangled Vines: Greed, Murder, Obsession,
and an Arsonist in the
Vineyards of California.
Her first book was Towers of Gold:
How One Jewish Immigrant
Named Isaias Hellman
Created California.
In 2009, Frances co-founded
The Berkeleyside,
a news site about Berkeley, California.
Berkleyside has twice won the
best community news site award
from the Northern California
Society of Professional Journalists.
In 2013, Frances and her
partner created Nosh,
a site about the food
scene in the East Bay.
Where were you born?
Welcome to Berkeley.
- Thank you.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born and raised in San Francisco.
- And, looking back, how do you think
your parents shaped your
thinking about the world?
- Well, my parents divorced
when I was very young.
When I was two years old.
And so, I was raised
primarily by my mother.
I did see my father.
But she was a single
parent for a long time
and I think what I really learned from her
was the importance of striking
out on your own in the world
and being strong and being
there for your family
and being independent.
So, I think, in many ways,
she modeled that for me.
And, you know, my father,
he was a lot of fun.
He taught me to ski.
He was into sports and that kind of thing.
And so, I learned that from him.
- And what were the examples
of what a woman could do
that you got from your mother?
- Well, I remember, growing up,
what women could do
was mostly be teachers.
And so, for a long time,
I thought I would be
a teacher growing up.
But my mother, at a certain point,
became a real estate agent.
And I remember her
studying to be a realtor.
She had to take some horrendous tests
that were very difficult.
And she passed those tests.
And she established her
realty business, I guess,
when I was maybe 10.
And that was a real change,
because she had been a stay
at home mom before that.
And, after that, she wasn't home
when I came home after school.
And that was a big adjustment,
but I did sort of see her
make her way in the world.
I think that that was the beginning.
It was the beginning
of changes about women.
And it started me on
the path to think that
women were not just there
to be married and pretty and smile.
That we actually had an intellect that
should be explored.
And, in fact, I always
hated it when I was young
when people would call me cute.
I always wanted them to call me smart.
- And where did you do
your undergraduate work?
- At Stanford University.
- But you said you went to
Berkeley for a semester.
- I did go to Berkeley.
I didn't love Stanford in the beginning.
So, I took a class during
the summer here at Berkeley
and then I applied for
transfer to UC Berkeley
and I was accepted.
But I decided not to go,
because Berkeley told me I had to retake
my freshman English class.
The one I'd already taken
at Stanford for pass/fail.
For whatever reason, that
was just too much for me.
I thought, "I can't do that."
- And what did you major in at Stanford?
- [Frances] I majored in history.
- In history.
And so, history is something
that's in your portfolio.
- That's true.
So, I'm a fifth generation Californian.
And so, I've always had...
Grown up with a lot of stories
about California and the family.
And I guess I just had it in my blood.
I just really loved finding out about
the world and different eras.
And so, once I started studying history,
I sort of never stopped.
- And your book about
your great-grandfather,
which we'll talk about in a minute,
proves you could be a historian.
- That's true.
You know, there is a thriving economy
of independent historians in the world
who aren't affiliated with universities.
And one of the reasons I sort of thought
I could go down that route was that
I did some work for a
man named Henry Mayor
who was an independent
historian in Berkeley.
And he had also been my English professor
at Urban High School.
And Henry wrote a number
of books that did very well
and were very well respected.
And he sort of showed me a path
that I could do this historical research
outside of a formal setting.
- I like to ask my guests
what skills, temperament,
are required to be a journalist?
- Well, curiosity, of course.
You have to like asking people questions.
You have to want to get to
know the minutia of a subject,
at least for a day or two,
in order to be able to write
about it in confidence.
You have to, I think, have
a certain amount of bravado.
Because, often, as a journalist,
you have to go into situations that
aren't necessarily comfortable
and you have to ask questions.
And you have to ask questions of people
who don't wanna answer questions.
So, I think that's something
that comes with time.
But you have to have the temperament
that you can allow
yourself to be disliked.
I think that's a very important thing
a journalist has to have.
- So, you moved into
doing an online newspaper.
You founded Berkeleyside.
Talk about how that came about.
- So, I became a journalist
after I graduated from college.
I worked in newspapers
in upstate New York.
And I came out to California
and worked for the San Jose Mercury News
for about nine years.
And it was a great job.
You know, I really enjoyed it.
I did leave the paper to
work on my first book,
Towers of Gold.
And, once I'd finished that book,
I was looking to do some more freelancing.
I'd done freelancing along the way
for People Magazine, New York Times,
lots of different publications.
And that was around 2006.
A time when newspapers in California
were really cutting back their staffs.
And the Chronicle went from having
300 reporters to 100 reporters.
And the first thing that was
decimated was local news.
And some friends and I were talking about
the fact that there wasn't a lot of news
and there was not a lot of
local news in Berkeley anymore.
There was The Daily Cal
and then The Daily Planet,
but The Daily Planet was having
some financial difficulties.
So, we thought, "Oh, let's
just start a local site."
It was sort of done on a whim.
And we were really surprised
at the reaction the site got.
People were very excited to
have a neutral news organization
writing about Berkeley.
And we just found that our
readership kept building.
And so, we sort of turned
this casual endeavor
into a serious journalistic enterprise.
- And how many views do you get a month?
- Well, you know, it really depends.
I mean, sometimes we can go
up to 300,000 unique visitors a month
when we have something really exceptional.
Some video or something.
But, right around now,
we're probably between
180,000 to 200,000
unique visitors a month.
And please remember that
the population of Berkeley is 112,000.
So, we draw from around the region.
Not just Berkeley.
- And Berkeley is a unique place
to be doing this sort of thing, isn't it?
- It is a unique place.
I mean, there's so much
news in Berkeley that
we can't keep up with our small staff.
And what makes Berkeley so interesting
is the university's here.
So, you have world class
intellectuals and professors
who are doing really interesting research.
You have the legacy of the '60s,
which transformed Berkeley from being
a more traditional Republican town
into a very leftist, Democratic city.
And, as a result of that,
people are very passionate about
a lot of issues.
And so, there's no such thing
as a small issue in Berkeley.
Almost every issue is a big issue.
And so, there's a lot of
good stuff to write about.
- So, what is the business model?
- So, the business model is
we are a for profit news site.
Though take those words
with a grain of salt.
We have a number of
different revenue streams.
We sell advertising on our site.
And we sell advertising
in our email newsletters that go out.
We have a very strong membership base.
People in Berkeley who are excited about
having a local news source sign up
to donate to our site.
$5 a month, $25 a month.
One time donation.
And that's a growing part of our business.
And the other thing we do, we do events.
In the fall, we have an event called
Uncharted: The Berkeley Festival of Ideas.
It's an ideas festival.
Really the only one in the Bay Area.
And, over two days, we bring
really extraordinary thinkers
in from around the country to talk about
what we might term dangerous
ideas or unusual ideas.
And usually it's on a one on one format
or someone gets up and
does a small performance.
It's not a conference, per se,
but it's more like a festival.
And so, we have about 400
attendees at Uncharted
and that seems to be growing every year.
So, that's another source
of revenue for Berkeley.
- And you also cover the news, right?
In other words, I notice
that you have links
to announcements that
have come out in the news.
- Yes, so, every day,
we do something called
The Berkeley Wire, which is
an aggregation of stories
from around the web about Berkeley.
And there are a lot of
stories about Berkeley,
like, for example, Chancellor
Dirks announced yesterday that
the university's facing $150
million deficit this year.
That's a story we linked to.
So, we just try to make it that
Berkeleyside is a one stop shop
for people who wanna
know about Berkeley news.
Not only the news that we
cover with our reporters,
the pictures that we have,
but also what other people are doing.
- And tell me about the opportunities that
online newspapers offer.
One of the things you said.
A lot of your friends were
being fired, basically,
as the employment in traditional
newspapers was declining.
- Well, it's very expensive
to produce news printed on paper.
And, as you may know,
the entire news business
is sort of imploding
and struggling to find
a business model that will work.
A number of newspapers
have gone to online only
or online two or three days a week
and delivery just a few days a week.
So, going online gives
you certain opportunities.
First of all, it doesn't
really cost much to produce it.
And, secondly, it can be
seen anywhere in the world.
You don't have to hold a
physical copy of Berkeleyside
to know what's going on.
So, people who are in Asia or
in France or in South America.
There are Berkeley residents
all around the world.
And we have readers who come from all over
to read the news about Berkeley.
And that's the advantage of online.
And it's also easy to
make things go viral,
because people put it
on Facebook or Twitter
and they spread the word online.
Which is not easy to do
with a paper product.
- So, this is the way
newspapers are gonna go.
Especially if they're
based in a local community.
Is that fair to say?
In other words...
- Well, the trend is
certainly in that direction.
You know, I haven't...
I don't see the San Francisco
Chronicle announcing
it's gonna cut its print edition.
So, I think we have a couple more years
before we see how things play out.
Certainly, the percentage of money that
newspapers are bringing in
through their advertising
in their print product
has dropped precipitously.
Pushing people to the web.
But I think there will always
be some large newspapers,
like The New York Times, The LA Times,
maybe The Washington
Post and The Chronicle,
that will have a print edition.
But probably, eventually, there will be
very few print newspapers in the US.
- And what is the biggest constraint
in doing a newspaper like this?
What are the main obstacles?
Some of which you didn't anticipate.
- Well, before I answer that question,
I think one of the main drawbacks
of an online publication only is that
you don't have serendipity.
I know that...
I often ready my New
York Times on my phone.
But I also get it delivered at home.
And, when you open the paper,
you sometimes are drawn to articles that
you might not otherwise be drawn to
when you're looking at them online.
So, that is one casualty of online.
What are the drawbacks?
It's very, very difficult to make
a viable business with the news.
It's, you know, we have
not yet mastered it.
We still need more revenue
in order to really succeed.
I mean, the jury's still
out if we will be here
10 years from now.
And a lot of the biggest
online publications,
like Buzzfeed or VOXX,
they're all financed
with venture capital money.
And, even though they get lots of readers
and they are getting advertisers,
they're still not really
paying their own way.
They're financed with outside money.
- And do you have advertisers?
- Yes, we have advertisers.
Lots of advertisers.
- Tess us about Nosh.
- So, Nosh is a very popular product.
You know that the Bay
Area is a foodie haven.
And the East Bay is a mecca for foodies.
And Nosh covers the food
scene and the wine scene.
And we launched it a couple of years ago.
And it's become very,
very popular, I think,
in part because it's mostly happy news.
I mean, it's mostly sensory
news and things like that.
Although I do a lot of reporting on wine
and there's been a lot
of local wine crime that
I've reported for Nosh.
So, there is, of course,
some hard reporting
going on in Nosh, as well.
- [Harry] And do you
recommend restaurants or...
- You know, we don't do
traditional restaurant reviews
like The Chronicle does.
But we introduce restaurants
and we show pictures of their food
and we talk about the restaurants.
So, when people are looking
for new places to eat,
they can come to Nosh to find them.
- So, let's now talk about your
first book, Towers of Gold.
This book is about your great-grandfather.
Tell us about how the book came about,
'cause curiosity led you
to the California Library
and you were expecting to
find a couple of letters.
But you found a lot more.
- So, I took a leave of
absence from The Mercury News
because I wanted to try
some other kind of writing.
I thought I would do
some first person essays.
And, as I was doing those essays,
I thought, "Well, I'll just
stick a little family history
in these essays and it'll
make them more interesting."
So, I knew that my
great-great-grandfather Isaias Hellman,
his papers were at the
California Historical Society.
So, I thought I'd go down
there for an afternoon
and sort of look through them
and use the information I
gleaned for my personal essays.
But, when I got to the
California Historical Society
and asked to see the
Isaias Hellman papers,
the archivist said, "Sure,
but which box would you like to see?"
And I said, "What do you mean?"
And she said, "Well, we have
40 boxes of Hellman documents."
So, that was a very big surprise to me.
And I started combing
through these documents.
And I started noticing that
there were all these letters from
these iconic California figures,
like Henry Huntington, Collis
Huntington, Levi Strauss.
And these were people who were
Isaias Hellman's friends
and business partners.
And the more I looked at these documents,
I realized that there was
a great untold story in those boxes
about the rise of California from
a frontier economy to a modern economy.
And I decided, "Well, maybe I should
write a book about Isaias
Hellman and tell that story."
- So, curiosity led you to the library.
But then talk about your emotions
when you realized the
kind of boxes upon boxes
of his work were available.
- Well, I think writers
choose a subject always
and there's some
psychological reasons for it.
Maybe the writer's not
necessarily aware of it
when they choose that subject.
And I think, for myself,
I explained my parents'
divorce when I was two.
And my father died when I was 16.
And I didn't really
know him all that well.
And, although I knew
his side of the family,
I didn't know them well.
And so, I do believe I was on some quest
to sort of reunite with the
Hellman side of my family.
And so, by going through these boxes
and finding out about this history,
it led me to sort of learn
more about this family
that I was a part of but I
was really estranged from.
And it was a great journey,
because Isaias Hellman
came to California in 1859
a penniless Jew from Bavaria.
He'd been...
Jews were not citizens
in Germany at that time.
He came to California,
which was not a country
that had a strict hierarchy.
People had come here to get rich off gold.
It wasn't like the east coast.
And Hellman came to
California, moved to LA,
and he eventually rose to become
one of the most prominent
financiers and bankers
on the Pacific coast.
Eventually owning Wells Fargo
Bank and other institutions.
And so, that was a pretty
amazing Horatio Alger story.
- And what was in these boxes?
In other words, was it the chronology
of his whole business career?
- Well, not everything was in the boxes.
But a lot of things were in the boxes.
Like, in the first box,
there was a report card
of his from Germany in the 1850s.
And letters from his brothers.
Letters from his relatives.
There were business
letters, as I described.
There were prospectuses for bond deals.
There were lists of his
wife's shopping expeditions,
which was great.
The clothes she bought
and things like that.
He was a packrat.
So, he even saved stuff like
when he had a receipt
from buying a newspaper.
That was tucked in his papers.
And there were just some
really, really great surprises.
I came upon this folder.
And there were all these telegrams about
"Thank God the assassin's
bullet went astray.
We're so happy you're alive."
And all this stuff.
I didn't know what that was.
And I had to do some research
looking through old
newspapers to find out that
someone had tried to
assassinate Isaias Hellman
in the 1890s in San Francisco.
And that was a story
that had never made it
down through the generations.
But the clue was in those papers.
- And we have to say here...
I wanna separate what made
him a successful businessman,
in your view.
The skills that he had
developed in Germany
or that he developed over time here?
- That's a good question.
I mean, it's impossible,
really, for me to know.
I think he was a very,
very, very smart man.
I think he came to California
and he must have carried the burden
of generations of Jews before him
who had not been allowed
to work in the professions
that they wanted.
Jews were very limited
in what they could do.
His uncle was a cattle dealer.
His father was a weaver.
And, suddenly, he arrived
in the United States.
He had some bookkeeping training.
And he went to work in a dry
goods store of his cousin's.
And he apparently immediately
improved their business.
So, I think he had an
innate business sense.
And he just sort of
followed that instinct.
He started to buy land
in southern California.
And he opened his own store.
And it was almost by accident
that he opened a bank.
And, of course, the bank was really
his first major accomplishment
as a businessman.
And so, I think he...
Banks were illegal in
California for a very long time,
because the lawmakers thought California
could be run on gold or coin.
And so, he opened a bank
when it was illegal.
And he had to feel his way
how to make that bank succeed.
And I think he taught himself a lot
about finance along the way.
- And, when we compare him,
he's a venture capitalist,
it sounds like.
Is that fair?
- A little bit.
Both a banker and a venture capitalist.
- In an environment where...
California hadn't developed yet.
So, he was also a visionary.
In other words, he, having
accumulated money in banking,
he saw what would be worth investing in.
- Exactly.
Yes, so he invested in the
water company in Los Angeles.
Everybody remembers, you
know, Chinatown the movie.
Well, Isaias Hellman, until 1902,
owned the majority of the stock
in the Los Angeles Water Company.
And he eventually agreed to sell it to LA.
He was very involved in laying
down trolley rails in LA
and got involved in power and land.
He was a UC regent.
But, yeah, California was a frontier.
I mean, when he arrived,
there was no scheduled stagecoach service
between Los Angeles and San Francisco.
There was no train.
There was no real telegraph line.
And so, a lot of the people
who came to California
in the 1850s got in on the ground floor
of investing in a lot of
these infrastructure projects.
You know, a lot of
people went bust from it.
Isaias Hellman did not.
Which I think suggests he was really
an extraordinary businessman.
But there was tremendous opportunity
in California at that time.
- And, by investing in all these things,
he really shaped the future of California
whether he stayed in a business or not.
- Well, yes, absolutely.
I mean, he played a very big role
in a large number of businesses.
And, as he became a
bigger and bigger banker,
he started something called
The Farmers and Merchants
Bank in Los Angeles in 1871,
which was the first successful bank in LA.
And it brought capital to the region.
Also, California was starved
for large capital for building.
So, he bought capital.
He eventually bought something
called the Nevada Bank,
which he merged with Wells Fargo Bank.
And he was able to help people raise money
to do a lot of projects around the state.
- And I want to talk about his identity
as a German, an American, and a Jew.
Because he was very committed, it seems,
to his American identity.
Talk a little about that.
- Yes, he was very committed
to being an American.
I think, as I mentioned earlier, America,
and California in particular,
had been really good to him.
He flourished here.
However, he was also very Jewish.
He was involved in building
the first synagogue in Los Angeles.
He was involved in the
synagogue up in San Francisco
when he eventually moved up here in 1890.
And where his identity as
being an American and a Jew
sort of started to conflict
came around World War I.
Because there was, of course,
this whole rise of the Zionist movement.
And there was this...
After Russia had killed so many Jews
during the pogroms of the
early part of the 20th century,
there was a real push to create a homeland
for Jews in what was then Palestine.
And Isaias Hellman felt
very conflicted about that
for a couple reasons.
Number one, he felt Russia and Poland
and all those countries should make Jews
citizens of those countries
and give them full rights,
which they did not have.
Or he felt that Jews in
America had great opportunity.
He was very concerned that,
if you created a state of Israel,
not only would you be pushing
out the Arab population,
but then Jews would be shunted aside.
They would be told to go to
Israel as opposed to America.
And he felt that America
was the greatest country
and that he was an American first.
And that that was really important.
And that other Jews should
have that opportunity.
- As somebody who is a family member,
but a researcher and a journalist,
what do you see is his greatest success
in a very successful career?
- That's a really good question.
Well, I do think the
fact that he was Jewish
and he made such a large contribution
to the development of California
is probably his most significant legacy.
But, clearly, Wells Fargo Bank
is his masterpiece or whatever.
He purchased the bank in 1905
at a time when the banking business
was sort of a minor part of Wells Fargo.
It had been primarily an express
business up to that time.
And he helped turn it around and make it
a really strong bank.
And he died in 1920.
But, after that, the bank merged with
hundreds of banks around the country.
And, now, it's one of the dominant banks
in the United States.
And, clearly, that wasn't
Isaias Hellman's doing.
But he certainly laid
the foundation for that.
- You know, your second books is called
Tangled Vines with a secondary title,
Greed, Murder, Obsession and an Arsonist
in the Vineyards of California.
So, what led you to this book?
It seems like there was a connection,
because your great-grandfather
had invested in wine.
- Right.
So, there was a connection.
So, that was one of the interesting things
I found out when I researched
Isaias Hellman's life.
That he had bought a
controlling interest in 1901
in something called the
California Wine Association.
And I didn't really know what that was.
And it turns out that the
California Wine Association
was a monopoly that eventually controlled
80% of the production and
distribution of wine in California
until Prohibition.
It was this enormous
operation that had vineyards
everywhere from southern California
to Napa and Sonoma.
It had huge wine processing
facilities around the state.
And it sort of had a lock on
selling wine around the world.
And I didn't find a lot of books out
about the California Wine Association.
So, I always had it in my mind that
I might want to write more about that.
And then, in 2009, I was
freelancing for The New York Times
and I pitched a story about
a trial that was coming up
about a man named Mark Anderson
who had been charged with setting a fire
in a wine warehouse in Vallejo
that destroyed four and a
half million bottles of wine
worth a quarter of a billion dollars.
Making it the largest wine involving...
Excuse me.
The largest crime
involving wine in history.
And, while doing that, I
remembered that I had a cousin
who had put a bunch of
wine of Isaias Hellman's
in that warehouse.
And that wine had burned up.
And that wine had been made in
1875 in southern California.
And I had known about it,
but I hadn't really thought about it.
So, I wrote that story
for The New York Times
and then I just started
to think harder about
what was lost when all that 130 year port
in Angelica was burned up.
Did it matter?
Wine is meant to consume.
Does it matter if someone
drinks it or a fire destroys it?
And that sort of got me on the trail
to writing a story about the crime
and about this vineyard that
these bottles came from.
And the vineyard, as it turns out,
tells, really, the story of
the history of California
sort of in a nutshell, as well.
- And what is it about wine?
You were obviously fascinated
for personal reasons.
But, throughout history,
wine fascinates everybody.
It's elixir.
But something else is going
on, as your book proves.
- Right.
Yeah, so that was also a
question I wanted to explore.
Why do people like wine so much?
I mean, if you think about
it, the Greeks and the Romans
both had wine gods.
People don't worship milk
the same way or even water.
And so, I tried to ask
a lot of people about
why they liked wine so much.
It turns out, I think,
that people like wine
because it makes them feel good.
You drink it, you get
a little intoxicated.
Or you just get a nice, warm glow.
And it sort of breaks
down sort of inhibitions.
And so, people are able to come together
when they drink wine
and they're able to connect in a way that
they might not otherwise connect.
And I think that this
is really a major reason
why people are so fascinated by wine.
And, of course, it can be an
intellectual endeavor, as well.
Because wine has its own history.
It has its own characteristics.
You know, one wine made from
grapes grown on one vineyard
may taste very different from
grapes made from a vineyard 10 miles away.
You open a bottle of wine
at the beginning of dinner.
That wine might taste
different at the end of dinner
as oxygen sort of pervades the wine.
So, it's a beverage that has
a lot of different components to it.
It's almost like it has a personality.
And I think that's why people
are so interested in it.
- And also it seems like
you're suggesting, implicitly,
that it reflects, wine reflects
some of mankind's worst characteristics.
But also some of its most
noble characteristics.
Because vineyards are often
owned by small families.
Small business owned by a family.
And so, talk a little about that.
Because there's the good and the bad.
And it seems to attract
quite a number of scoundrels.
- You're absolutely right.
I mean, I think when we
think of the wine business,
particularly living in the Bay Area,
we think about the bucolic Napa Valley
with its undulating hills of grape vine
and its beautiful blue skies.
And the great wine and the great food
you can have up there.
And the Napa Valley lifestyle,
which is something everybody can enjoy.
But, as it turns out, there
is a very dark side to wine.
Almost beginning from its
origins in California.
The first winemaker was
Father Junipero Serra.
A Franciscan missionary who
created the mission system.
And he imported wine cuttings
from Baja California.
And, to grow wine, he
used the Native Americans
who had converted to
Christianity to make that wine.
And, of course, those Native Americans,
once they got in the mission
system, they couldn't leave.
And, in many ways, they were
like indentured servants.
And that relationship between wine making
and indentured servitude
for the Native Americans
really continued through the 1870s.
The Californians treated
the Native Americans badly.
And the very first law passed
by the California Legislature
in 1850 was nicknamed
the Indian Indenture Act.
And it allowed white people to identify
a Native American as drunk or indolent,
at which point a sheriff could
arrest that Native American
and fine him.
And, generally, the Indians didn't have
money to pay the fines.
And so, the sheriff would then auction off
that Indian's labor to the highest bidder
at increments of a week at a time.
And the sheriff would
pocket a percentage of that.
And the municipalities, like Los Angeles,
would pocket the rest of it.
And so, the early history
of wine in California
really was based on sort of slave labor.
And I think this is something that
people don't really know.
I mean, I didn't know.
And I had no idea about it.
And it is one of the ugly
aspects to wine history.
But there are other ones, too.
Greed.
The subtitle of my book has
greed and murder in there
because there's a lot of greed
and murder in the vineyards.
- And, interestingly enough,
it's not just individuals whose sordidness
is reflected in the wine this
gentleman who burned down
the warehouse where everybody's wine was,
which was a real tragedy for people
who have wine there for many reasons.
But you tell the story of
how the bubble before 2008
came to the wine industry.
And the exorbitant prices that
were being paid for a bottle of wine
in the neighborhood of 200,000 plus.
But, in the end, the wines were faked.
So, it's a product which
even the master class can be taken in
by what they're buying.
So, there's kind of a
prestige in owning the wine
that may be worthless,
but I'm willing to pay
200,000 for a bottle.
- So, like any product,
when something is rare
and people want it and
people are willing to pay
very high prices for it.
So, probably the most
coveted wines in the world
are French wines.
French Burgundy is very
desired, as is French Bordeaux.
And, in 2008, sort of the
auction world changed,
because Hong Kong lowered the taxes
it charged on importing wine.
And this sort of created a frenzy in China
for people who wanted to buy
this very expensive wine.
And they started bidding crazy prices
at auctions around the world.
And there was a man named Rudy Kurniawan
who was an Indonesian man
living in southern California
who sort of took advantage of this.
He had a really sophisticated palate.
And he, I guess, came
from a family of means.
And, for a long period of time,
he was just buying bottles and
bottles and bottles of wine
and sharing it with a lot of people
who called themselves Young Turks
who had made a lot of
money on Wall Street.
And so, there was this
frenzied environment.
And what Kurniawan
eventually ended up doing
was he would take some
of these original bottles
and go to restaurants and
share them with his friends.
Dropping $300,000 on his black AmEx.
And then he would ask the restaurants
to ship the bottles back to his home.
And, once he was at his house,
he would concoct fake versions
of fancy Burgundy and Bordeaux.
And then sell them as the real thing.
And he actually...
This auction house called
Acker Merrall in New York
conducted two auctions
of Kurniawan's cellar
and sold his wines for
millions of dollars.
And some of the most
important people in the world
bought that wine, including William Coke,
who is the brother of the Coke Brothers.
He bought a number of bottles of fake wine
from Rudy Kurniawan.
Anyway, Kurniawan was eventually arrested,
charged, and convicted of fraud.
But what's happened is William Coke
has been public about all
the bad bottles he bought.
But a lot of other people
who bought bad bottles
are hiding them because
some people speculate
they want to get rid
of them on the market.
They don't wanna announce
that they bought bad wine.
So, it did cast a pall over
the whole high end wine market.
- And so, the bottom line
is people don't often know
what they're getting.
Grapes are stolen from land and
then sold as something else.
In his case, he was using old bottles
to prove the value, which was a lie.
- Right, wines are faked
all around the world.
They're usually high end wines.
But it's a big problem.
It's a growing problem.
And, you know, it's one where
probably a lot of fake wine
gets out on the market.
But I would say most of that fake wine
is gonna be at the level, probably,
that you don't drink or I don't drink.
It's for people who really
spend a lot of money on wine.
It's not gonna be your
average $25 bottle of wine.
- This gentleman, Mark Anderson,
he was a real scoundrel and
he burned his warehouse down.
You tell that story very effectively.
As a family that had some wine there,
what are your feelings when
you realize that it's happened?
- Well, Mark Anderson
set this fire in 2005.
And it destroyed a lot of wine.
And it ruined a lot of
people's businesses.
The wine...
Some winemakers were told
by their insurance companies
that they were not insured for that wine.
Because it was in transit.
And so, a number of people
went out of business.
You know, a lot of winemakers
lost placement in restaurants,
wine lists in stores.
And it took them a couple of years
in order to get their wine
back up on the market.
So, it was a very devastating
fire to the wine business.
For my cousin who had put the wine
from my great-great-grandfather
in this warehouse,
she'd actually lent it to a winemaker
who had put it into the warehouse for her
without her permission
and without her knowledge.
She was really devastated.
Because she felt she was supposed to be
the caretaker of this wine.
And that she thought
she was doing a good job
trying to sort of make
it last and she didn't.
Her actions sort of
led to its destruction.
So, I think she was
really distraught about it
for a very long time.
And, in fact, I did open some
of this port for my book.
And I invited her to come and join me.
And she just didn't want to
have anything to do with it.
She just...
She really can't even
think about the episode.
So, I mean, I think that the way she feels
is how thousands of people feel.
The fire ruined the vintages
of 90 wineries in California
and the collections of
44 individual collectors.
- What lessons do you think you've learned
from your career that you
might pass on to students
who envision being a
journalist slash historian?
- Well, so, for me, what
really drives me are stories.
I love finding good stories.
And I think, of course, as a journalist,
there are a million stories
every day that are great.
But I think there are
also lots and lots of
fabulous stories in history that
have not been told or haven't
been told in a very long time.
And could be told in
a very engaging manner
that reaches a broad audience.
And narrative nonfiction is
becoming more and more popular.
And I think that's because
people love stories
told in an exciting manner.
So, I guess I would
encourage people to go out
and go to the Bancroft Library.
Search through the
files and find something
that looks untold and interesting.
And try to tell it in a magazine format
or a book format or something.
- And how do you develop the skills
to tell somebody else's story?
- Well, that's a good question.
I think that that takes time.
I think you have to do a lot of writing.
And journalistic writing is very different
from writing a book.
I mean, when I wrote Towers of Gold,
I had to sort of teach myself
how to write in a different way.
I had to teach myself how to write a book
that had a narrative arc.
That it was scene-based.
That was character-based.
Trying to draw things
out and engage readers.
And that took a lot of experimentation.
But I think I eventually succeeded at it.
So, I think you have to
take off your journalism hat
and put on your sort of novelist hat,
even if you're not a novelist,
to tell those kind of stories.
- And what will online
journalism do to storytelling?
Will it further it or undermine it?
- I think it's furthering it.
I think there are lots of great websites
that have long form journalism on them.
There's some really
good reporting going on.
And getting a book published
is really hard to do these days.
You know, you're supposed
to have a platform.
And, even if you get a book published,
it's very hard to get a book noticed.
There's so many books that are coming out.
So, there are alternatives
to writing a book.
One of them is finding a great website
and publishing online.
- And what role will video play
in telling the story online?
- I think video plays a
huge role, as do images.
I mean, people like to look at pictures.
It's hard just to look at type online.
And graphics do very well online, too.
So, nowadays, when you
train to be a reporter,
unlike when I was training,
you don't just learn how to write a story.
You learn how to do a podcast.
You learn how to do a video.
You learn how to combine
all those things together
to tell a story.
So, there's a new kind
of journalist out there
using all those techniques
to sort of get the news out.
- Well, on that note, I'm
gonna thank you very much
for coming on our program.
And we will look forward
to going to your websites
and buying your books.
And what is the URL for
Berkleyside and for Nosh?
- Okay, so, Berkeleyside
is berkeleyside.com.
And you can find Nosh on Berkeleyside.
And my website is francesdinkelspiel.com.
- Okay, alright, well, thank
you very much for joining us.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(relaxing music)